Bon comme c'est mon dernier jour chez Tao
Je me suis dis que quand même j'allais vloger un petit peu cette journée
Avec mon retour à Paris pour vous faire voir où j'était durant une semaine
Et c'est la maison où le wifi fonctionnait le moins bien au monde!
Toutes les vidéos de la semaine j'ai dû les télécharger en 4G depuis le téléphone
J'ai donc cramé tout mon forfait 4G en fait en quelques jours
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai pas beaucoup répondu aux commentaires non plus
Là vous reconnaissez, c'est où j'ai fait la vidéo avec Tao
Ici, c'est son espace bureau.
Là, vous avez une partie de ces accessoires de magie
Qu'est ce qu'il y a dans la valise d'un magicien ?
Olala je suis en train de tout faire voir.
Ce sont de grandes illusions ou alors ce mec fait vraiment des soirées chelou en fait !
Mais c'est possible hein, ça peut servir aux deux d'ailleurs.
L'un n'empêche pas l'autre !
Et içi vous avez l'atelier de Mme Tao, de la femme de Tao.
Voilà, ça c'est pour le sous sol et maintenant moi je vais prendre mon café
parce que si je ne prend pas de café, je..je vais abandonner toute cette vidéo.
Mais nan ! C'est gros bouddha qui arrive
C'est le gros Bouddha ! *rires*
Haha putain..
T: La forme Mister ?
F: Ça va et toi ?
T: Bien réveillé ? Aller c'est le dernier jour je te fais la bise
F: Ah ils ont bouffés le jeu de cartes de Tao *rires*
T: Bon y'a...
F: Sans déconner
T: Ils y en a qui sont mortes mais ça va, on a pu en sauver les 3/4 !
F: Alors pour ceux qui se pose la question, Bouddha il a 1 an...il a 1 an et demi?
T: Il a 1 an et demi là
F: 1 an et demi donc il est bientôt bon à être consommer *rires*
T: 3 mois
F: Et Lucky il a 3 mois
T: 3 mois...
F: Il a des pattes ENORME Lucky !
F: Bouddha le seul problème, c'est qu'il est persuadé d'être tout petit
T: Ouais *rires*
F: Il est persuadé d'être tout petit et tout fragile et du coup c'est un espèce d’hippopotame le bordel
F: Oh il a fait pipi...On a le droit au petit pipi du matin qui fait plaisir.
Comment s'amuser avec des chiens sans se fatiguer...démonstration de Tao.
T: Quand vous êtes vieux, quand vous avez pas le temps, quand vous êtes feignant au sport.
T: Attention ! Lumière...GO
*rires*
F: Lucky il court après Bouddha, Bouddha il sait pourquoi il court mais Lucky non.
Et là maintenant on est dans le haut de la maison.
Dans la chambre de Tao évidemment !
En fait c'est Tao qui tient la chaîne "Studio Bubble Tea" vous saviez pas ? *rires*
Et on va bosser sur son spectacle !
F: Juste tu prend celle du dessous et ...
Durant ces quelques jours, on a essayé d'écrire toute une structure au spectacle de Tao
de trouver un thème, un univers
Et là on est en train de dépiauter ces numéros, on regarde tous les numéros qu'il a et qu'il a tourné un peu en vidéo.
On est en train de les analyser, de resserrer, de recouper, de rechanger des trucs.
F: Voilà on a pris comme le thème le Portugal
T: Voilà *rires*
F: Qu'on soit bien d'accord, on arrête les clichés les vietnamiens ne mangent pas de chien...ce sont les chinois qui font ça !
F: En vrai les vietnamiens mangent des...
F et T: Chats
T: Des chatons même, c'est comme le veau hein, ça coûte plus cher
*rires*
F: C'est ignoble *rires*
Et même si je suis chez Tao et Aurore, il faut quand même que je monte la vidéo donc c'est parti pour 1 heure et demi de montage du MentalVlog !
Pour cette dernière journée Antoine nous a prévu une bonne surprise
On va manger typique, on va manger local, on va cherche un...?
T: Kebab
F: Un kebab *rires* un kebab...
T: Tenu par mes cousins
*Rires*
F: T'as de la famille partout
La famille de Tao rachète tout en fait, bientôt Limoges s’appellera "Litao"
Bah oui parce qu'à Limoges quand tu veux un kebab faut prendre la voiture *rires*
*Musique forte*
T: La technologie hein...Pourquoi ça MARCHE PAS
*rires*
T: Concentre toi là
F: *bruit forçage*
F: C'est bon t'as rangé le bipeur ?
T: C'est bon
Oh ce bon repas...ce bon repas équilibré qu'on fait avec Antoine.
T: Coca, kebab
Car oui Tao s'appelle Antoine
Je viens de révéler ta véritable identité
T: Tu dois avoir du sang Japonais toi avec ta caméra partout, c'est comme les Japonais là *rires* avec leurs bus
T: Appareil photo, caméra...
F: Ah oui, parce que je vous l'ai pas dit mais il est raciste des Japonais.
C'est un chien mouton, c'est un mélange de chien et de..*rires* Bouddha...Bouddha le jaloux
Et voilà au final j'aurais passé 7 jours chez Tao, Aurore et Andréa bien sûr.
Et je suis en train de préparer mes bagages pour aller prendre le train.
Enfin le train si j'en ai un, puisque pour l'instant le train que j'avais réservé a été annulé
Merci les grèves !
Et il a fallu que je choisisse la couchette supérieur ou inférieur
Ça c'est un vieux réflexe de colo de "Je veux le lit en haut s'il y a des lits superposés".
Mais on sait pas pourquoi on veut le lit du haut, mais on veut le lit du haut !
Donc j'ai pris le lit du haut.
Et s'il y a des couchettes, est ce qu'on m'oblige à dormir du coup durant le trajet ou est ce que c'est un peu libre ?
Je ne sais pas, je vais le découvrir.
T: Service de l'immigration
F: Oui, ok mes papiers
T: C'est combien ? Faut payer combien
*rires*
T: Ça y est monsieur vous êtes arrivé à la gare !
Y'avais bien des couchettes dans le train que j'ai pris, alors j'ai pas osé filmer parce qu'on était 4
et c'est euh...c'est assez serré diront nous donc j'osé pas trop filmer
Je pense que je serais passé pour un ouf durant tout le trajet
Merci d'avoir regardé ce Vlog.
Petite information, je vous ai mis un message sur Facebook, Twitter, Insta et Snap ce matin.
Pour savoir qui voulais faire une vidéo avec moi demain.
Vous savez que le mardi je mentalise quelqu'un.
Là j'avais pas grand monde cette semaine puisque j'étais chez Tao.
Donc ce soir à 21h, je fais un Skype avec l'un ou l'une d'entre vous !
Allez voir sur Facebook, je vous explique comment ça se passe.
Je fais le tirage au sort à 20h30 !
N'oubliez pas avant de partir également de laisser un petit pouce en l'air du lundi qui va faire plaisir pour toute la semaine.
Et comme le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour.
Rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !